[Music]
let's hear this is video 4 so the
[ __ ] got this far probably means
you're gonna go very very far in
property investing the last video sorry
I had to cut that little bit short but I
do his videos in a 15 minute timer so
this one's going to be a bit shorter
today but lease option agreements and
vine provinces no money
hopefully you may got some value from
that and honestly the information alone
from this book and especially you
attended my two-day crash course that we
had one guy who turned up to the crash
course he didn't speak a word of English
practically he was really in a
translator with him and I just thought
um geez they asked they requested that I
could get a translator at the front
house they can oh my goodness there was
300 people there so I said I can't do
that but we set this little deal up for
him and he was there and I was kind of
thinking not very lovingly or compassion
that I was thinking he's he's a drag to
the to the group this big property
investors crash course 300 people and
others as a guy Nick sat next to me was
free Lizzie it translating it was quite
annoying
however this guy couldn't speak any
English he went out from the two days
and secured himself a lease option
agreement so I thought how wrong was I
know those moments when you realize how
stupid you were so what I'll say is it's
very doable just gotta take action
remember what I said in the first video
knowledge + action equals massive
success we had another video the one
before that which was about what areas
to buy I talks about how everything
follows London and gave some predictions
and also showed you how to work out
return on investment which is
effectively where you take the profit
that you're making the annual profit and
you divide that by the amount that you
invested which gives you a percentage
figure which is your return on
investment
typically if it's less than 20% I'm
gonna touch it it's 25% boom if it's
close to 30 then you're absolutely
laughing lease option agreement some
some of the no-money-down stuff will
give you an infinite return on
investment I mean just think about it
imagine that you found a deal
you needed 20 thousand pounds to buy it
and it was going to give you a 20%
return on investment but you haven't
money so you borrowed 20,000 pounds from
a bank or from a friends and you pay
them ten percent interest they're making
ten percent you're making ten percent
but they're making ten percent of their
money spent you're making ten percent of
nothing you spent and you you're the one
with the house so I mean anyway there's
so many ways to buy property within no
money but I've really like this option
agreements but we do have four four ways
there which you'll understand on the
crash course we'll go through and then
the first video was just about mindset
the seven lies again I talked about this
that in the book which is an Amazon
bestseller by the way again thank you if
you've reviewed it already of note I've
noticed as I've put a lot of reviews in
the last few days so thank you ever so
much if you've done that if you haven't
please go down and do it I'm read and
appreciate every single one this video I
want to give you a few golden nuggets
and one two three four five six six ways
you can source them to then go ahead and
buy the first way is what you need to do
if you're serious if you want to find
properties and you want to attract below
market value deals and really high cash
flow properties you need to do this you
need to tell the world you need to tell
everybody that you're a serious property
investor and that you are actively
looking for properties do videos put
change your facebook your profession to
property investor if you're currently a
solicitor great on your Linkedin on your
Facebook you ships a solicitor and
property investor tell the world in
Ezekiel in the Bible it says write down
the vision make it plain so that all the
world can see because when you start
speaking something out into into
existence and saying this is what I'm
gonna buy this is what I'm looking for
suddenly the dealers will start coming
to you so tell the world
don't be a closet secret property
investor let the world know what you're
looking for and you've got to decide as
well what you're looking for you've got
to figure out what are your living
expenses get that figure in your brain
and then set out to earn that figure in
passive income work out a game plan of
what you what how many properties you
need to get financially free this is
something that we go through on the
crash course we're getting care
employment for you and then get out
there and start telling people what it
is that you're looking for so tell the
world next number two networking
effective
networking can and will replace
expensive advertising join local
networks near your house where the area
is where you're planning on buying fine
networking groups BNI Bob clubs foreign
property investors Network pin run by
Simon Zushi brilliant network while I
myself run something called the property
investors circle where we have a network
of property investors some are newbies
summer serious property investors and
then other people are in the property
trade so just get down and start
networking stop rubbing shoulders with
people and when you're networking don't
don't try and get business don't try and
get deals when you go network inc try
and help other people because if you
help enough people get what they want
you'll get what you want so you want to
help people if someone stands up and
says I'm looking for X Y & Z and you can
help them go try and give it to them
help other people and then when they go
geez that was really helpful how can I
help you you can say I'm glad you asked
I'm looking for a hexam owned property
in Bradford and I need a Powell team in
the area do you know anybody that could
help me and watch what starts happening
watch the connections the power team the
leads the deals that stop coming your
way so networking 3 is estate agents I
became an estate agent for three months
just to make friends and for free
education I was in 2010 I owned it for a
few months but it was great I learned
some really interesting things so if you
want to find deals from estate agents
I'm gonna give you a few steps to do
that but first let me tell you this most
property investors start investing they
get their deals from estate agents when
they become a seasoned pro then they
turn their nose up at stage agents and
say I'm going to find my own off-market
deals thank you very much and then when
you become really seasoned and matured
as an investor then you go back to your
estate agents because the bottom line is
this estate agents do have the best deal
why well because there are hundreds of
thousands of properties on the stages
books right now and as long as you are
in their little black hop book and they
know that you're serious investor then
they'll give them you before they even
go on Rightmove
if there's something that they think
that
good HMO or that could be a really good
casket and they understand you then you
will be into getting the best deal some
of them will be off market some of the
market but the bottom line is there are
very good deals on estate agents so here
are some tips one
remember that estate agents are not
property experts they're salespeople
that happen to sell property really
really important so don't be intimidated
by estate agents at all
- they'll often try and sell their
services to you ie we're going to use
our mortgage advisor and we'll use our
solicitor do not turn your nose up at
the estate agents offer and say oh no
thank you I'm a professional investor
and I have my own team don't do that why
because they'll just think that you are
suck up and they won't give you the
deals best thing to do is this safely
estate agent you know what I actually do
have my own team to deal with my
mortgage and almost misters I'll be very
happy to come in and meet you meet meet
your team and have a cup of coffee
that's what you need to say if they say
yeah come on in go on here and meet them
have a cup of coffee build some rapport
don't have a lots and lots of mortgage
checks on you because it can affect your
credit but if you have to go and get
checked out and find actually qualified
once or twice and in a over a span of a
year that's fine so going in and then
step number three is don't put in
stupidly cheeky offers to estate agents
if you just say twenty twenty percent
BOV on this twenty and just offer 20
percent below the asking price on
everything you say
you're gonna lose friends and not
influence people so don't do that
instead tell the estate agent what are
you looking for and be professional
about what you're doing and you know
find motivated sellers that want to sell
their property at 20 percent below
market value and then you can work with
them rather than just go we're seeing an
approach it's irrelevant what the house
is on the market for the bottom line is
what's it worth so sometimes the
investors they just put 20% below market
value on everything they say and then
finally they come across someone who's
got the house on for 100 but it's only
worth eighty thousand and you go on off
at eighty and they say alright then and
you think you've got a fantastic deal
but really it's only worth eighty anyway
so just just be honest do you teach
diligence be
thrown and build relationships with the
estate agents so that's a really good
way to get deals I get a lot of deals to
estate agents in fact I've got such a
good relationship of estate agents
probably shouldn't really say this but
they sometimes will get a property
before it's even on the market Suze they
get the keys they'll swing by my barn or
my office mansion where we live at the
help at all and now just say here the
keys going up a lot timber what you
think they won't even go there because
we've got that kind of a relationship so
that's what you're really headed for
next is advertised so again like any
business you know you're gonna need to
advertise I personally spend a thousand
pounds a week on Facebook at where I
advertise to potential motivated sellers
and that's where I get a lot of my leads
from but you might not want to do that
because it's pretty advanced I mean you
can stop by just leave for dropping just
leave the drop in houses in fact in this
book on page 109 I've got a really neat
letter which I send to which I send to
people selling their property and I drop
it in the door I'll post it out to them
and I've got the template inside this
book so if you've you can rip that off
no problem in other ways auctions
auctions could be fantastic the only
problems of auctions if you don't know
what you're doing you can get really bad
so I'd say unless you've been trained
professionally by someone that knows
what they're doing in auctions probably
best to steer clear of auctions and then
the last way is to buy properties of a
sorcerer someone who is found the deal
for you that's a really neat way because
it can save you a lot of time means
you've not been advertised no you're
networking you've not been doing any of
those things I do that I buy properties
from sources I even source properties
myself because it's really annoying when
you know you're waiting for a bus and it
comes and then after a couple of hours
three come at once that's exactly what
happens in the property world I'm always
searching always advertising properties
I might suddenly get ten in the gutter
and I cannot take them all on so I will
regularly pass properties on to my
contacts and when I do that I include a
Power Team I do all the due diligence
and absolutely everything so if you're
interested in that side of things then
what I would say is below on this link
it says how to become a cherry pick
member and what that means is when I
pass my deals out
if you're choking them but you won't
just get any deal you'll get the best
feels hand cherry-picked on myself on my
team and that we sent to your inbox
first so it's a really cool way to get
the best deals is to become a member of
the shape club
but generally speaking sources are a
really good way just make sure that
you've done your due diligence on the
sorcerer so you know when you're buying
off a sorcerer you need to do due
diligence on the sorcerer had they got a
good track record have they so I
probably should just find once more to
start with and then see how it goes
doing the figures and then if it works
out then you can go hardcore with the
sorcerer so the world it's two videos go
networking when you go networking don't
go to get go to give and then you'll end
up reaping what you sow make friends of
estate agents and remember that they are
on your side because they want to sell
houses you just need to be honest with
them and build a relationship with them
advertise or if you can't be bothered to
advertise you don't want to take the
risk with the budget find a good
sorcerer and someone that can package
deals for you if you are interested in
in the HMOs the lease option agreements
and the really high return on investment
properties that I source then below on
the link I would suggest that you sign
up for a cherry-pick member you pay a
very small monthly retainer fee to
filter out the serious people and you'll
get the best deals if you don't know a
little bit more about how my sourcing
business works then always suggest going
on this thing right here and you'll get
to see a little bit about how it works
and see an example of someone who's
sourced a property through myself before
so until next time have a fantastic
evening and I'll see you on a fifth and
final video very soon
[Music]